continúa la información aquí en las 24 y
hablamos ahora de economía estamos para
eso con nuestra periodista daniel
hablando que nos va a contar lo más
importante hoy también la bienvenida y
empezamos hablando de francia que era su
millonario plan de estímulo para su
economía hacia el liliana muy buenas
noches pues el objetivo desde aquí a
2022 salir de la profunda recesión en la
que entró este país a causa del
coronavirus con inversiones por 100 mil
millones de euros de ese total 35 mil
millones irán para la competitividad a
través de reducción de impuestos a la
producción industrial lo mismo va para
el empleo sobre todo para fomentar la
contratación de jóvenes y el resto será
para establecer políticas energéticas
amigables con el medio ambiente como por
ejemplo implementar la bicicleta como
medio de transporte en este país
escuchemos
familia 100.000 millones de euros es
cerca de cuatro veces más que el plan de
recuperación que había sido tenido en
cuenta para hacer frente a la crisis de
jason 2020
a un oposición ahora dices esto en
proporción a la riqueza nacional el plan
de reactivación es el más masivo
anunciado hasta ahora entre los grandes
países europeos por mi libro pepe y
tropea bueno daniela hablamos ahora de
méxico que está mejorando la tasa de
desempleo cuéntenos emiliano le tengo
una noticia buena y una mala la buena
noticia es que en julio 1.5 millones de
personas se incorporaron a la población
económicamente activa pero eso no quiere
decir que estén empleados sino que son
mayores de 15 años que trabajan o que
buscan empleo pues por eso es más
preciso mirar la tasa de desocupación
que en julio fue del 5,4 por ciento un
poco más baja que hace un mes pero mucho
más alta que el 37 por ciento de hace un
año que viene la mala noticia lo que sí
está creciendo liliana es la
informalidad si en junio el 53% de los
que trabajaban eran informales ahora lo
son casi el 55 por ciento también se
estima que en lo que va corrido de la
pandemia se han perdido 12 millones de
trabajos formales
bueno pues vamos a hablar ahora una
noticia que tiene que ver con economía y
con medio ambiente porque la unión
europea quiere reciclar para reducir el
uso de minerales de las llamadas tierras
raras bueno primero empecemos para
explicar que son esas tierras raras pues
son un grupo de 17 metales
indispensables para fabricar baterías
celulares televisores y muchos otros
aparatos electrónicos y se llaman así
porque no es habitual encontrar
yacimientos con grandes cantidades la
unión europea prevé que de aquí a 2050
necesitará 60 veces más litio y 15 veces
más cobalto para fabricar baterías de
autos eléctricos y el suministro depende
de china chile y sudáfrica por eso lanzó
hoy un plan que consiste primero en
intentar reutilizar reparar y reciclar
estos productos y segundo establecer una
alianza con otros países como canadá
la verdad es que dependemos en gran
medida de materias primas insostenibles
de países con estándares ambientales y
sociales denso más bajos menos
libertades economías pobres e inestables
necesitamos diversificar la oferta y
hacer un mejor uso de los recursos
disponibles dentro
la unión europea donde aplicaríamos los
más altos estándares ambientales y
sociales para tal efecto estándar
bueno son interesante veremos que
pasaban y era brasil emitió el billete
de 200 reales cuentos de qué se trata
liliane pues se trata del billete de más
alta denominación hasta el momento
emitido y se esperan unos 450 millones
de ejemplares el banco central de este
país advirtió que ahora en la pandemia
hay más demanda de efectivo pero también
más acaparamiento de los ahorradores
si usted cambia un billete de estos por
dólares recibe aproximadamente 37 así
que muchos no están tan contentos porque
les será más difícil encontrar cambio en
las tiendas y me quedo en américa
latina' liliana para decir una noticia
muy pequeñita y es que la ex presidenta
de costa rica laura chinchilla retiró su
candidatura a la presidencia del banco
interamericano de desarrollo hay mucha
polémica por el candidato de eeuu y
porque a pesar de la presión de los
países de la región no se han aplazado
estas elecciones que son para este mes
bueno daniela cuéntenos cómo están los
indicadores de la jornada bueno después
de varios días
'wall street' aterrizó y sufrió su mayor
caída en tres meses días de fuertes
descensos en los tres principales
índices resultados dispares por su parte
en las bolsas de europa hubo pérdidas en
londres y parís y ganancias en madrid y
en américa latina' los principales
mercados cerraron en rojo arrastrados
por la bolsa de nueva york gracias
daniela por la información de colombia y
este gracias por estar en france 24
contribuyen con más en nuestra página
web france24 puntocom nos vemos más
adelante
i